bonjour à tous bienvenue pour cette
foire aux questions stop sciences où on
revient à nos premières amours c'est à
dire les dinosaures et en particulier
les dinosaures français alors pour
parler des dinosaures français
j'accueille aujourd'hui thierry tortosa
docteur thierry tortosa y est
paléontologues
récemment diplômé de l'université paris
6 et du muséum d'aix qui donc a fait sa
tête et bien sûr les dinosaures d'aix en
provence en face sur les vertébrés en
général du bassin sédimentaire d'aix en
provence sous la tutelle de eric du sto
et le gîte chez nous donc eric buffetaut
pour ceux qui connaissent les dinosaures
c'est un nombre je pense que tout le
monde connaît on ne présente plus et
donc thierry basset en quelque sorte la
relève de la paléontologie des
dinosaures la relève ses listes alors
ben du coup bienvenue et ma première
question c'est si tu peux nous parler un
petit peu de ton travail de ta thèse les
dinosaures d'aix-en-provence déjà
qu'elle dinosaures quel est ce qu'on a
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de dinosaures
ce qu'on a un riche patrimoine dans la
région d'aix-en-provence
d'accord mais bonjour et merci déjà delà
de m'accueillir son ton sur ton émission
donc c'est une question déjà très
intéressante puisque le sujet de ma
thèse on ne parlait pas que les
dinosaures mais de tous les intégrer et
continentaux comme tu l'as où tu as
signé souligné mais au niveau des
innocents qui est des choses déjà très
intéressantes à dire puisque en fait des
dinosaures provinces sont connus depuis
longtemps
depuis la première moitié du xixème
siècle et depuis les toutes premières
découvertes jusqu'à jusqu'à
actuel on a eu beaucoup de découvertes
qui ont été faites beaucoup de
discussions beaucoup de polémiques et la
question du jour c'est est ce que les
dinosaures c'est pas tant de savoir
combien de dinosaures mais qu'elle est
quelle est vraiment la validité est de 2
du nombre de dinosaures qu'on connaît en
provence et et c'est une question
passionnante parce qu'on a beaucoup de
choses finalement qui apparaissent quand
on compte on se penche en détails sur
les comptes d'accor donc la validité
d'une espèce est ce que tu peux un peu
nous expliquait bon sens sans nous
réciter évidemment le code de
nomenclature internationale est ce que
tu peux nous expliquer ce que c'est que
la validité d'une espèce alors en fait
il ya deux cas de figure de dinosaure
qui trouveraient et ne plus être venir
en tout cas en province il ya les tout
premiers les premières de plus tard
qu'on fait qui ont été faites donc en b
1869 avec un des tout premiers
dinosaures dont des clients provence qui
s'appelait le lycée l'autobus donc c'est
un fameux amenant un célèbre 90
dinosaures provençal qui a souvent été
d'ailleurs à coller avec les oeufs de
dinosaures qu'on découvre en provence
difficile aux russes qui a été décrit en
1869 et qui est maintenant
malheureusement un an un autre dinosaure
invalides pourquoi tout simplement parce
qu'à l'époque comment quand les premiers
ont été découverts et décrit par un peu
notre logo jules haag qui donnait
ensuite paléontologue philip
m'interrompt il a décrit dans qu'un
dinosaure a plutôt un reptile
gigantesque sur la base d'un ou deux
eaux qui malheureusement n'était pas si
informatif que ça donc avec les
découvertes qui ont été faites
ultérieurement on s'est rendu compte que
le monde vont poser sur rien de concret
donc ça c'est un premier cas de figure
on a un nom dinosaures qui qu'il est
fini c'est un os qui qui ne l'est pas
beaucoup d'informations finalement donc
le nom est devenu no men google ait été
abandonnée par la suite l'autre cas de
ces deux figures est un autre cas assez
célèbre en provence là ça concerne les
tanneurs app store qui ont été
découverts dans le bassin d'aix en
provence mais aussi dans le var du côté
de boxe en fosse à lisier une une
discussion à dire entre entre
paléontologues français sur la base
d'idées la validité d'un accent ses
dires d'un
d'un genre de dinosaures donc d'un côté
on avait une bulle tôt et jean
villeneuve qui avait découvert variés à
tort un rapport qui venait de troubles
dans le bar avec d'autres ou d'autres
ossements qui qui provenait du bassin
aix en provence du côté de beaurecueil
ou qu'il a sa victoire et de l'autre on
avait l'équipe de kim tak et de ja et de
ronan allain pardon pas d'un acquis qui
avait décrit piot raptor olympus qui lui
vient d'un gisement précis du bassin aix
en provence est donc là il y avait une
polémique sur la validité de varga tort
ou sur celle de piora tort selon le
l'école qu'on suivait d'un côté donc on
va dire que philippe taquet et ronan
allain reproché à victo et j'enlève
d'avoir attribué la victoire en fin
d'avant d'attribuer un nom des éléments
au ce qu'ils n'appartenaient pas au même
animal qui connaît donc depuis lancé
depuis leurs gisements et dont les
éléments n'étaient pas forcément très
informatique très diagnostic comme andy
et de l'autre donc que manipule tout
élève qui soutenaient la validité de
leurs leurs taxes aux élus que s'il
s'agissait du premier nom donné à ce
sera à se donner aux hommes il est donc
à ce rapport
selon light est plus valide au détriment
du second qui était apparu par la suite
ça c'est un résumé très limpide pour
éclaircir la situation sur ce deuxième
qui de l'amabilité de n'ont encore rien
pourri de châles aux riches
effectivement je me rappelle quand
j'étais gamin j'avais les dinosaures de
a à z
il y avait chez laurus de torreilles
silhouette énorme de dinosaures à long
cou donc les sauropodes saison il n'y
avait aucun élément ou social assez gros
dinosaures et alors là l'histoire de
pierrot raptor et devra maintenant elle
est super intéressante parce qu'il faut
préciser c'est qu'en fait les éléments
au ce de pyro instauré de paris raptor
ne se superposent pas c'est à dire qu'il
n'ya rien de comparable
aucun élément qui est comparable entre
l'un et l'autre squelette en fait
jusqu'à maintenant parce qu'il est en
ondes en étudiant un peu les collections
diverses et variées de provence on peut
trouver des petites choses qui peuvent
être comparable donc
regardez ça pour la suite et donc la
solution à toute cette grosse discussion
je veux pas dire polémique mais
discussion va voir un dénouement plutôt
heureux je pense donc donc ça fait
partie des bad et des surprises qu'on
peut avoir quand on étudie du matériel
qui écoutiez gardés dans des dans des
collections
pas forcément fraîchement sorti du
terrain et pour revenir à pour venir
avec soul aux russes effectivement c'est
un gros dinosaures titanosaures je vais
pas dire le nom de la famille mais il
représente quand même l'un des plus gros
qui est another découvert en province ce
n'est pas le plus gros mais d'après les
quelques éléments fragmentée a été
trouvé on a un animal de trait au style
donc le record n'est peut-être pas
encore battu depuis 1869 d'accord donc
en fait on a un taxon qui n'est pas
valide une espèce n'est pas valide mais
on sait quand même que c'est une espèce
à part on sait qu'on ferme c'est que
c'est un tyrannosaure parce que les eaux
sont des eaux de titanosaures parce
qu'on n'a pas on n'a pas plusieurs
grandes villes de ce repas dans en
province on n'a que des tisanes 11 ans
puisque improviste la preuve du
contraire et aux salles de tous les os
de tous les ossements comparer de
titanosaures va se mixer nous aurons
atteint entre guillemets pied
l'autoroute est le plus gros enfin les
éléments sont les plus gros de ce qu'on
a pu découvrir en provence d'accord ça
c'est assez surprenant d'avoir cessé
kroes ossements de dinosaures en
provence puisque la provence à l'époque
en tout cas au crétacé puisque toi tu
est spécialisée sur la période du
crétacé supérieur
cette allée à l'époque la provence
c'était là un petit coin deal au milieu
des tropiques qui éventuellement vous
ferez peut-être pas assez de ressources
pour supporter une population entière de
dinosaures de cette taille pour indice
parents considèrent généralement pour un
disque un fossile découvert représente
en fait dix mille individus vivant dont
fossilisés donc ça voudrait dire que
rien n'est véritablement une grosse
population de ces dinosaures géants en
provence tas d'avis là dessus
oui alors en fait enfin comme je le vis
la provence appartient à une île qu'on
appelle
libero armoricaine qui est constituante
de toute la provence voilier avec une
partie du sud ouest de la france peut
être l'armorique seconde période et le
nord de l'espagne donc cette grosse île
dans la plupart des reconstitutions et
quasiment de la taille de madagascar
entame superficie par contre l'inconnu
de cette île c'est sa superficie sur des
courtes périodes de temps on peut savoir
sur 40 millions d'années mais après dans
le détail peut-être que sa superficie a
évolué et donc ce qu'ils vont faire des
dinosaures en fait c'est qu'on ait deux
problématiques d'un côté on contredit le
nombre de grosses espèces qui pouvait
lui en sur cette île aussi la diversité
sachant que l'on peut pas avoir une
diversité gigantesque sur une diversité
très très grande sur sur une île de
taille moyenne si madagascar peut être
considérée comme une que 1000 de taille
moyenne et d'un côté on peut pas
vraiment plus aucune classique des
espèces de trêve en taille puisque les
ressources sont limitées
mon avis sur la question ben on a
d'autres on a trouvé des os on a des
gens de petite taille
ça me pour par exemple titanosaures
bougherra boudon qui sont les deux les
deux dinosaures des pluies les plus
communs en province
donc on a des labos de grosse taille des
rangs de l'anp petite taille on a des
titanosaures de grande taille de petite
taille un peu partout en sur cette île
libéraux armoricaine ça se voit par
exemple dans l'oeuvre dans l'hérault
dans le nord d'espagne on a une vie aux
heures de grande taille
donc s'ils sont là c'est un moment donné
les ressources ont été assez suffisante
pour que des populations de 12 ans en
individuel pu se maintenir alors après
sur combien de temps ça on ne sait pas
sur quel air exact de lille centre s'est
pas non plus mais les gisements sur
lesquels ont trouvé des ossements sont
la preuve concrète ces animaux de grande
taille est on bien parcouru la maman
donne donc tout là toute la
problématique en fait de ma thèse aussi
de ce sujet était de savoir sur combien
de temps ces dinosaures n'ont pu être
présents
est-ce qu'ils ont été contemporain ce
que l'équipe formée et et contemporaine
des grosses forment ce qu'on sait que
sur les sur les îles on a on peut avoir
des phénomènes d'évolution insulaires
qui mèneront au nanisme
donc même au gigantisme donc donc la
question était de savoir déjà en
repositionnant
précisément les gisements dans le temps
savoir si on avait affaire à des
dinosaures qui étaient contemporains et
on se rend compte que week sur certains
gisements on a trouvé une idée
titanosaures main et j'y ai de très
vastes oeil dans les mêmes eaux couches
fossilifères donc c'est intéressant
parce qu'après ça ça ramène à d'autres
questions pagnoux écologique savoir à ce
que ces animaux sont donc ces mêmes la
même nourriture on de mêmes plaintes
puisqu'on sait maintenant qu'il peut
pour certains enfin dans certains
certaine période de temps il est
étonnamment contemporain ouais donc par
rapport à la paléo géographie alors ceux
qui connaissent peut-être pas trop le
dossier faut faut quand même voir que
pour ce qui est de la paléo géographie
de cette île sud de la france il n'y a
pas deux auteurs qui a dessiné la même
carte à windows c'est pas facile de se
retrouver dans cet environnement là
c'est plutôt compliqué de ce faux déjà
d'abord oui comme tu l'as fait remettre
les espèces qui vivaient ensemble par
dessus une carte est arrivé à voir s'il
ya une certaine cohérence
paléoenvironnementales qui on sort sans
trop spoiler à thèze au niveau nombre
d'espèces et les synchronicité de ces
espèces
on partirait sur combien en fait pour
faire simple on va partir sur les
familles il ya ensuite au sein de ces
familles on peut détailler ce qu'on peut
trouver ça spoliés comme tu dis donc
déjà on a on va commencer par les
herbivores donc le dit leur argument le
plus commun le plus connu plus fréquents
scélérate dedans qui appartient donc à
une famille en mx2 le dinosaure
indélicats l'europe l'érable de nantes
idée donc je dis aux honorables dedans
on est un peu l'emblème des tno en
province pour le crétacé supérieur
puisque
les squelettes les plus concluants ont
été découverts en inde où je redonne en
provence donc c'est un animal un animal
qui connut par deux espèces dans le sud
de la france
on a 2 dont presque us qui est étudiée
par permettront et donc qui est le
premier dinosaure découvert enfin pas
découvert mais décrit par 1869 à
l'équipe c'est le zoo russe mais qui
n'était pas considérée comme mineure à
l'époque donc radieux dans priscu s'est
ensuite on a dans les années 90 ramadan
septimanie q ce qui est électrique dans
l'hérault donc les deux espèces de
différencie sur les caractères de la
mâchoire faut savoir que bon sur les
autres îles de l'archipel européen de
cette époque la nôtre redon idée qui au
départ étaient considérés comme des rats
dedans mais qui ont été ensuite rangé
dans d'autres dans d'autres genres
mais voilà en tout cas pour abdou non on
a deux espèces à ce jour sauf que une
étude récente menée par des collègues en
bois sur des sur l'histologie aux 16 de
ces dinosaures ont révélé qu on avait
peut-être enfin en avez sûrement une
troisième espèce art 2 en 1 qui
parcourait la province reçoit bonne on a
vu les différences de taille qui a entre
autres cet adulte très petite taille et
les adultes qu'on a pu trouver très
proche enfin quasiment contemporain là
on a peu de doute sur le fait qu'il
s'agit d'une nouvelle espèce donc ça ça
tu es partie des des futurs des cultures
description qui seront donnés et fait de
ce matériel là sachant qu'on a on a de
nombreux éléments qui ont été sortis sur
ses agissements sur ce gisement qui
adresse c'était lyon darbo tendent à
savoir il faut il faut s'attendre à voir
une diversité d'érable de renty des
ibères en france et qui pourrait
augmenter de manière intéressante
donc ça c'est corps à 12 ans ensuite
autre dinosaure pour un stade
emblématique dans ce sens l'état n'a
donc moins que celles aux russes était
un titanosaures qui n'est plus valide
à ce jour on assure les libéraux
american iii titanosaures qui sont
valides à ce jour là on a en provence à
tsinga la zoologie de lausanne 6 donc un
titanosaures de taille moyenne entre 8
et 10 mètres de long qui était découvert
sa commune de vélo ensuite on a le
fameux
auquel aux russes attaqués ce qui vient
de bien de l'aude qui est inquiétante et
à mesure qu'ils pouvaient atteindre plus
de 15 m de long 1 donc sans doute le
plus gros titanosaures de cette île
inconnue à ce jour
et ensuite on a un troisième kitano aux
harkis qui étaient découverts en espagne
dans les pays basque espagnol s'appelle
green aux russes
s'il y avait donc là aussi elles
titanosaures de taille de plus petite
taille 1 entre 8 et 10 mètres de long
donc une diversité de titanosaures race
est assez élevé puisque jusqu'à présent
mais on pourrait avoir encore des
surprises puisque au sein du matériel du
sud de la france on a du côté de
l'hérault sans doute une nouvelle espèce
qui va atteindre être en provence on a
une qui sera quittera bientôt décrite
donc que ça laisse présager là aussi une
belle augmentation de la diversité et je
ne parle pas du matériel espagnol qui
qui est en cours description qui
pourrait aussi donner des bébelles des
belles surprises pour les sites à noosa
grave dans qui étaient les plus gros
herbivores donc des gens on se rend
compte que sur cette île les plus gros
herbivores étaient déjà assez diversifié
alors ne sont pas strictement
contemporain on va dire à quelques
millions d'années près mais enfin je
veux dire au sein des millions d'années
ils sont contemporains mais ensuite
quand on rentre dans la centaine de
milliers d'années là c'est plus délicat
pour savoir mais on se rend compte quand
même qu'on a qu'on a cette diversité de
gros herbivores qui en pièces et riches
plus riches que ce qu'on imaginait il ya
matin à rien par exemple on imaginait qu
au maximum on pouvait avoir une à deux
espèces en profanant science est il donc
ça c'est pour les gros servira ensuite
on a les petits arbres morts comme une
ode aux orchidées qui sont des petits
animaux cuirassé donc ce sont les
cousins des fameuses 1 kg à vide et
nord-américains et asiatiques qui sont
connus pour être très très fortement
blindé avec des plaques au ca sur le dos
même une masse yeux ou de l'alcool en
nous chez les mènent aux envies des qui
sont des versions miniatures
on n'a pas cette nationaux d'accueil
mais on a quand même des tacos à ce qui
leur permettait de se protéger comme
moment on n'a qu'une espèce qui est
valide
dans toute l'île ibéro-américaine ses
structures aux russes languedocienne si
ce qui est un cousin des formes
hongroises et roumaines contemporaine
pour le mans pourra pas savoir si on a
plus plus éléments puisque le rap us de
d'espèces pour pour ce genre là puisque
puisque matériel est très fragmentaire
très très rare c'est un animal qui
étaient très rares paradoxalement même
s'il était mary d'une grande quantité de
d'éléments ce s'anime à la cera donc on
espère trouver d'autres
d'autres carcasse d'autres cadavres de
ce dinosaure pour enrichir nos
connaissances
est ce que sont les trois arbitres bande
et plus les plus communs on a ensuite
les arrosant donc les fameux dinosaures
à bec de canard qui sont apparues à la
fin du crétacé supérieur donc la moitié
du mas tricher en tout cas pour en
partie française de l'île
peut-être un peu avant dans les
gisements espagnol donc il faut savoir
qu'en france pour maman n'a qu'une
espèce qui est valide c'est canard dia
et ce taxes on l'a donc s'aligner avec
de canal et peut-être envie bien
peut-être différent de ce qu'on a trouvé
en province de manière très récente
après l'espagne en a plusieurs autres
taxes ont comme parlant arabe d'oran
mais on a moins de trois d'action
différent en espagne donc à la question
par contre cette sale race qu'il n'y
aurait pas d'aidés d'état que sont
synonymes enfin qui sait remontant au
niveau des carnivores je tiens à
rappeler avant un vin de patek les
carnivores car à briller quand même très
célèbre pour avoir découvert arrco
venator en tout cas dans la communauté
des dinosaures au lot c'est quand même
toi qui a découvert la dernière espèce
de grand dinosaure carnivore en france
oui tiens le rappeler et si vous êtes
derrière vos écrans
applaudissez le parce que quand même
c'est vraiment un très très beau boulot
qu'il a accompli d'ailleurs toute la
tête ça a été un travail extraordinaire
j'ai oublié de le dire tout à l'heure je
suis désolé de te couper la parole mais
pour vraiment voir le travail qu'il a
accompli c'est un truc formidable un
volume gigantesque de boulot qu'il a
abattu et qui est kim paradoxalement
quand loin d'être terminée je te redonne
la parole voilà aussi pour ses
compliments en tout cas
oui la chance de travailler sur sur les
restes qui en clans permis l'inscription
d'un coordinateur
je suis pas le seul c'est comme qui
trouvait le dinosaure tout seul dans les
juges moi donc c'est le travail conjoint
de toute l'équipe du nouveau mission
naturelle d'aix en provence dont bon
nombre sont co auteur de la découverte
mais aussi d'eric bulteau qui inquiète
et associés donc cette belle découverte
et à la description de ce beau l'île aux
noix c'est même si elle s'incarne ivoire
pour manier très joli donc voilà donc un
révélateur
on va commencer par les gros du coup
belle transition anglais gros carnivores
il faut savoir que que sur cette île
hillairaud américaine n'est qu'un ivoire
a été assez mal connue en fait on y
arrive on est assez mal connu jusqu'à
très récemment passe quand on sait juste
qu'elle a juste à mon travail à notre
travail sur sur les teasers kownator
alors on se doutait bien qu'il y avait
dix à billie holiday qui qui parcourait
la province depuis les années 80 la fin
des années 80 puisque bulteau avait
décrit un max hilaire de nom de provence
qui laissait déjà présager de la taille
de la présence d'un gros carnivore de
belle taille en provence mais il y avait
une polémique sur l'attribution de ce 2
c ce maxillaire à savoir à ce que
c'était vraiment un habit livre idées ou
est-ce que c'était un
carcharodontosaures idée pour ceux qui
qui s'y connaissent un peu en gros
carnivores du gondwana
je donnais rapidement quelques exemples
d'abbé l'isr idée qui serait inconnu
fakir la plus grande popularité en fait
au sein des habits l'hybride est le plus
connu est sans doute carnotaurus chi chi
et sud-américains donc été découvert en
argentine fameux conte dinosaure
carnivore avec ses cornes au-dessus des
yeux qui a été la star d'un des films
d'animation disney à une certaine époque
donc carnotaurus que tu es un animal pas
très très bourrin il faisait entre huit
toiles à 8,10 m par contre après il y
avait des plus gros comme à belize au
russe qui a donné son nom à la famille
des amis des idées parmi les autres
dinosaures les attraits billy the kid
est connu on amazon gaz au russe qui
vient de madagascar qui est connu par
respect d'être complet c'est pas le seul
puisque bientôt on aura la description
complète de sportune scorpio been a tort
qui est aussi un autre
déçu bien par contre de nouveaux sud
américain mais assez complet donc ces
animaux emblématiques donc originaires
des commandes de l'hémisphère sud vont
du gondwana de la sq en contenant du
mans grenat sont surtout caractérisée
par une morphologie crânienne assez
assez surprenante dont toujours des
cornes ou des protubérances osseuse qui
rendent leur crâne à ses
caractéristiques en fait chaque chaque
genre à un crâne particulier donc c'est
le cas de robin a tort qui a des goûts
relais au saut au dessus des yeux un des
caractères qui qu'on peut retrouver deux
formats c'est assez proche et d'autres
habitants du triplement terre n'est pas
exactement sous cette forme-là donc
l'asse c'est la belle idée qu'elle est
plus gros sourcils au feu et donc voilà
donc la question était de savoir si on
avait ses habits l'isoler en provence ou
des carcharodontosaures l'aider donc les
carcharodontosaures il est sont les plus
gros carnivore qui vécut en seconde on a
surtout dû surtout durant le pl est
assez moyen entre guillemets avec à 40
en afrique du nord mais en amérique du
sud on a des gigues hanotaux rue sous la
pluie ou russes enfin matusow gus qui
sont qui sont également de très gros
carnivores c'est ce sont les équivalents
des tyrannosaures mais dans l'hémisphère
sud
en voilà donc la polémique portait sur
l'attribution ce maxi l'un et avec donc
la découverte darko venator qu'il eut
lieu entre entre 2008 pour l'extraction
des premiers ossements et 2013 fin 2013
pour la destruction du matériel
maintenant on est sûr à 100% qu'on est
bien de déshabille l'iso reid en
provence donc avec un commutateur est
spontané mais peut-être un attaquant on
aurait d'autres puisque on a d'autres
dans qui proviennent de différents
gisements de 2,7 y lire le week end et
donc ils n'ont pas tout à fait les mêmes
caractéristiques de que celles qui sont
qui sont rapportés à covina tort et
celles qui appartiennent au maxillaire
qui lui même pourrait être un maxi
verdun commune à tort il faut attendre
la découverte
complémentaires qui pourraient être
faites dans ce type de la france ou même
en espagne pour prog lente et cette
diversité là tout en restant chez les
habiller les à billie joe biden on a des
espèces de plus petite taille
alors pour ceux qui connaissent un peu
les dinosaures de province on à tarascon
au russe qui a été longtemps la figure
emblématique des bizots vidé en entrant
même si encore une fois c'est ces
ossements étaient discutés par certains
certains spécialistes qui trouvaient que
le matériel était trop fragmentaires
pour que ça soit vraiment vide d'un
pokémon sont valides et c'était des
réseaux retail
je ne sais pas d'où vient ce mythe mais
a toujours été considéré comme un gros
animal quand on voit les reconstitutions
de tabasco horizons pour un animal qui
avoisine les 8 à 10 mètres de l'en but
en fait c'est un tout petit tout petit
animal qui n'est pas si le palais les
quatre mètres de long d'après les
ossements qui ont été trouvés et quand
on compare ces ossements ben on se rend
compte que c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose qu'à notre faim car corinne à tort
voilà vous allez me dire les eaux sont
pas directement comparables c'est pas
les mêmes c'est pas les bentos mans sauf
que on a eu notre habilité qui a été
découvert en province du côté de six
tombes qui s'appelle généraux russes six
taureaux ont dit qu'ils lui il date du
crétacé moyen et haut ce petit habile
uribe qui était jusqu'à présent à ranger
dans une famille notre famille de
labelliser euro id
c'est à dire le coût frère d habiles
horrible mais qui est finalement bien à
la mise hors ib lui à du matériel qui
permet de faire la comparaison entre
rares communes à tort géniaux mus et
arras columbus et quand on fait le tri
qu'on compare dans l'ensemble de ce
matériel qu'on fait la compilation se
rend compte qu'on a bien deux branches
en tête des bilans livrés en transe les
gros et ceux de petite taille donc le
tarascon russe et généraux russes sont
pour moi des specs valides sont pas du
tout quand 1 pour rennes en tout cas
entre tous les jours ils s'intéressent
pas aux russes et terrasses russe
lui-même n'est pas content pour à leur
commune à tort donc d'un point de vue
stratégique rafik ça n'a pas de problème
pose problème hier qu au niveau du
matériel bon on a des différences qui
permettent de soutenir dans leur
validité est pas lui mettre en synonyme
donc voilà les gros car il
entre guillemets on a déjà ce donc ces
deux ces deux familles la c2 sous
famille puisque en fait c'est toujours
toujours des amis du rugby mais il faut
pas oublier ensuite une autre phase iib
donc très présente un en provence
beaucoup plus petit c'est la famille
d'eads remis aux autorités donc les
fameux rappeur qui comme je lé deal son
sang présenté par voirie raptor et ou
qui ont raptor sans dévoiler le résultat
des recherches et ce matériel donc en
fait l'élément autorisé par contre on en
trouve partout partout sur sur les
libéraux amérique armoricaine alors
malheureusement il n'y a pas eu encore
d'études le synthétique de tout ce
matériel là mais au niveau de la
province on a en plus de la discussion
sur qui on retrouve un capteur la
présence d'un mode qui a reçu plusieurs
appuis lyon monde différent selon mais
selon les spécialistes
on a entendu beaucoup de choses comme
par owni co2 au monde où monique aux
dons ricard de lester vient donc ont
assez peu cette petite forme de drôme et
aux hormones qui est arrivé aussi en
province pour juste de notre zone
donnerai pas le résultat de mon travail
en disant qu'elle est à quelle est leur
vrai nom de cette petite espèce là mais
il ne faut pas l'oublier
donc au moins au niveau des droits mais
autorise des on a au minimum deux et
trois espèces en provence mais encore
une fois voilà ce sont des petites
espèces on peut avoir une diversité qui
pourrait être revu à la hausse
je terminerai donc ces universités des
dinosaures par deux autres dinosaures
qui sont souvent oubliés parce qu'il
s'agit d'un oiseau donc je peux rappeler
mais dans les roseaux sont considérés
comme comme les dinosaures
donc c'est une branche de dinosaures qui
a perduré depuis l'extinction des
dinosaures et en province on a en aussi
les eaux
on a découvert par exemple sur évidement
varois des restes de
hunting motards ceux d'un petit oiseau
accords dits qui trône au zoo de petite
taille qui est volé est née d'un tueur
ni thèse qui n'a pas de nom pour le mans
puisque matériel très fragmentaire on a
trouvé d'autres restes de cette famille
d'oiseaux dans l'hérault donc c'est très
fragmentaires mais en comparant avec des
spécimens plus court plus complets
découverts dans le monde ans
on sait que ce sont des animaux de
petite taille dont la taille d'une
mouette par exemple qu'ils étaient
capables de brûler par contre quoi
surprise depuis les années 90 on sait
qu'en provence et aussi dans l'hérault
on à la présence d'un oiseau de tri
grande terre à terre c'est à dire qu'ils
n'étaient pas capables de voler et cette
ode a pris la taille des éléments
découverts deux bassins pour atteindre
sur les estimations et celles de mètres
de hauteur
alors ça c'est très particulier parce
que vraisemblablement il s'agirait d'un
oiseau herbivore qui vivait en même
temps qu'il faisait tout à fait
contemporain durable aux dons et du
titane joueurs donc ça suggère qu'ils se
mobilisent et de la note type de
végétation et c'est un animal qui
endémique
enfin pour mémoire d'amy que du sud de
la france mais mon jeu je mettrais ma
main à couper qu'on trouvera on en
trouverait ailleurs dans sur cette île
ibéro américaine et il s'agit du plus
grosse de swap terre connue pour le
crétacé supérieur de même pu prêter à
ces mêmes du mésozoïque au monde
donc voilà pour pour cette diversité des
de ces dinosaures provençaux ouais donc
la dernière sort de là peu une sorte
d'autruche quoi en fait
voilà au niveau de la taille en sait pas
encore à quoi ressemble et son crâne
puisque au niveau des éléments connus on
a eu une vertèbre cervicale quelques
sautes d'humeur en quelques bassins un
fémur au niveau de la tâche serait une
grosse autruches
après est-ce que c'est plutôt autruches
type
enfin c'est un animal plutôt de la
morphologie l'autriche plutôt ma
morphologie du gast ornis ou diatribes à
ça c'est la grande question sachant que
gaspard nice et rillettes rima ce sens
dès ce soir et eux-mêmes des gros zozos
donc par contre du tertiaire mais
herbivores et paquin erreurs comme ça
nantes ont été suggérées donc on a ces
deux types de morphologie crânienne qui
pourrait être possible pour un gargantua
liste franchement je la tarte écouter
est ce que tu racontes sa superbe je
crois que cette interview on risque
d'être longue
on pense alors à t'écouter
on comprend que que ces frais quoi tout
ce travail que c'est vraiment c'est tout
récent c'est la paléontologie c'est
vraiment pas la science à papy ou qui en
train de prendre la poussière comme les
fossiles qu'elle étudie quoi c'est
vraiment une science qui est vivante qui
arrête pas de se remettre en question
qui est sans cesse des nouvelles
découvertes est alors en plus une autre
idée reçue sera pas les autos c'est que
tous les paléontologues sont des sortes
de cowboy avec un chapeau qui vont
chercher des fossiles à l'autre bout du
monde dans toi tu fais des trucs battu
fait des découvertes avec toute l'équipe
du musée d'aix milano tu fait des
découvertes extraordinaires sur place
quoi chez nous en france tu mets en
avant de le patrimoine français alors ça
c'est vraiment deux idées reçues de la
paléontologie qu à toi tout seul tu es
défonce ça c'est super géologie maple
des chapeaux de cow-boy aussi jeter n'y
a que de family staff provençal s'est
pas trop compatible bas après sinon oui
bah c'est en fait ce qui me plaît dans
la paléontologie l'entamé d'une hausse
en tout cas pour ce que je suis c'est
qu'on a on est assis sur une mine d'or
quand on est en provence où la fronde
anti de la france et c'est une fille
très peu exploité leur paradoxalement
juste un petit point historique faut
savoir que les dinosaures provençaux qui
ont été décrits 1869 font partie des
tous premiers dinosaures décrit au monde
puisque bon pour le rappel les
dinosaures donc sont décrits en 1847 57
pauvre richard wayne 1509 serrano dont
hypnose
donc même s'il n'est pas considéré comme
un
comme un dinosaure il est considéré
comme un gros crocodile à l'époque c'est
pas beaucoup c'est un gros et qu'il gobe
team crocodiliens on y parle ce fait un
amateur on parle surtout d'un pinceau
rien s'il prononce pas sur le sur la
nature crocodile yen mais surtout sur un
saurien chose qu'on va retrouver à
cédric matray camarades lire avec les
autres découvertes qui ont été faites
deux premiers sauropodes en provence
durant le 19e siècle parce qu'on a aussi
épisode russe qui était découvert assez
tout parce que sa découverte elle date
de 1852 donc la c1 sanogo souvent c'est
pat it another man pour open mais aussi
a été pris pour un gros reptile donc au
quotidien mais plutôt un reptile marin
vu ses grosses dimension est dans la
nature des cds maintenant que nous avons
été trouvé donc les premières
découvertes de tin de titane aux héros
de ce report a été mal interprétés à
leur corps à bonon très rapidement a été
a été vu comme un dinosaure quoi oui et
donc que j'étais en train de dire
pendant que les dinosaures province au
conte partie des tous premiers
dinosaures décrit dans le monde donc la
paléontologie française était assez à
ces pionnières dans ce dans ce dans ce
domaine là il faut savoir aussi que
cuvilly regarder d'un oeil très attentif
à ce qui se faisait sur les dinosaures
même s'il n'a pas étudié de dinosaures à
proprement parler mais mais c'est grâce
aux travaux de cuvier qui reprenait
finalement les toutes premières
découvertes de dinosaures que mature on
a pu a pu décrire son rabot dont en se
comparant en se basant sur une dynamique
dont l'illustré par cuvier pour la
petite anecdote donc voilà ce qui est
dommage c'est que par la suite d'un
dinosaure de province soit sur tombé un
peu dans mobile
que ce soit enfin qu'il fallut attendre
finalement là la fin du xxème siècle
2010 maintiennent une siècle pour revoir
surgir les dinosaures et avec une grosse
centaine d'années de deux pauses bon on
a eu des événements historiques
géopolitique qui n'ont pas trop
contribué aider la science ici mais
c'est dommage de voir que qu'on ait pris
autant de retard par rapport à d'autres
pays comme les etats-unis ou la chine
maintenant qu'ils qui explose tout en
terme de découvertes et d'avancées
scientifiques allaient chinoises sont
sur plus forts que nous dans bien des
domaines
bon pour eux comme on dit les français
qu'on dit les français
impossible n'est pas français avant que
c'est justement su parler des
découvertes en france si je ne m'abuse
il me semble qu'un oeuf de dinosaure
aussi dans l'ariège qui avait été
découvert avant même l'invention du mot
dinosaures
alors oui lorsqu'il dinosaures
décoiffant les autres dinosaures c'est
bon ce soir aussi c'est une longue
histoire qui est intimement lié au sud
de la france il faut savoir qu
historiquement on attribue la découverte
d user aux américains avec des
découvertes qui ont été faites par les
équipes américaines et polonaises d'un
désert de gobi et des gets in a while
the dinosaurs voilà donc les fameuses
the dodos du raptor donc ça c'est la
moitié du 20e siècle et en fait non
parce que les tous premiers ne part pas
forcément de dinosaures mais tout
premier ceux qui sont maintenant 2010
nous ont été découverts dans ceux de la
france alors d'un côté on à charles de
peu de père et qui de son côté va dire
oui ce sont des oeufs 2
deux autres dinosaures villa ce serait
le premier à avoir avoir un tribut
laissa donc là il faut remonter à 1990
ou début du 20e siècle
mais d'un côté on affirme interrompre
qui est le premier à avoir décrit des
oeufs en tant que facile puisqu'il avait
étudié ces sphères et c'est le premier à
avoir interprété cela comme étant des
oeufs donc là ça remonte à 1860 par
contre voilà lui il attribuer cea ipsen
aux russes qui n'était pas considérée
comme un dinosaure
donc ça a été le petit le petit détail
qui qui l'empêchent d'être le père le
père la découverte des premiers doutes
dinosaures au monde donc c'est quand
même découverte française bien plus
l'intérieur que celle-ci l'américano or
polonaise mais en tout cas c'est ça
montre encore un croque des français
les français étaient promis enfin été
des pionniers dans l'appel anthologie
des dinosaures viennent à cette époque
là et je sens que faire peut être montré
dans la transition sur les autres
dinosaures de province et nos richesses
peut-être suis-je donc si prévisible
s'était passé quelque chose si facile
donc oui donc pour répondre enfin pour
anticiper ta question
les autres les un dinosaure pour qu'on
parle d'eux de dinosaures en provence
tout simplement parce qu'en fait le sud
de la france est mondialement connue
pour sa grande richesse en eux on a au
moins deux gros gisement dans le sud de
la france qui ont livré des oeufs et qui
sont connus pendant du côté pour en
salle des fameuses de la sainte victoire
il faut savoir qui s'étend sur une très
large sur la surface qui fait environ 60
70 km de long sur sur 30 km de large
donc toute cette surface de fouilles est
très riche en très riche en oeufs etc
sur tous les os de la sainte victoire
qui ont fait parler d'eux puisque dans
les années 60 une recrudescence de
découvertes sur certains gisements
notamment sur la commune de beaurecueil
qui ensuite vu la création d'une réserve
biologique empêchant toute toute
activité de pillage et même de
recherches paléontologiques tellement le
site était riche pour donner un petit
exemple dans le centre ville d'aix en
provence dans les années 90
entre 98 et 2001 il des campagnes de
fouilles qui ont été faites en plein
milieu du centre-ville sur des sites e
de dinosaures donc on est tombés sur des
sur décisivement de nidification c'est
environ un millier deux qui ont été
trouvés répartis sur une certaine de
ponte
alors tout ça et conservés au muséum
d'histoire naturelle d'aix en provence
ça n'a pas encore été totalement et
qu'il y ait donc on espère bien avancé
sur le comportement une étude des
comportements de ponte de dinosaures
mais en tout cas ça montre bien au
niveau de la densité de ce qui a été
trouvé au centre-ville et 200 province
qu'on est assis sur faire on à
l'expression marcher sur des oeufs
on peut l'appliquer déjà de crétacé
supérieur parce que là on marche
littéralement littéralement sur des
gisements à eux deux le dinosaure tout
dernièrement sur le sur la réserve
géologique de beaurecueil donc réserve
biologique centimes sans victoire on a
découvert sur 25 mètres carrés de
fouilles plus de plus de 100 e répartis
sur trois niveaux stratigraphie
différents donc ainsi très très riche
on espère que ce sera le prochain gros
gisement qui sera exploité qui est très
loin d'avoir livré tous ses secrets en
terme de donc ça c'est pour le côté
provençal mais après effectivement dans
dans sud ouest on a des choses
le gisement le plus connu c'est celui de
rennes le château donc elle aussi
inconnue pour d'autres d'autres faits
historiques mais là on a eu des fouilles
importantes qui ont été menées dans les
années 2000 entre 90 et 2000 pas aussi
aboutie qu en provence mais qui ont
montré que qu'on avait des choses qui
pouvaient dit sur la méthode de ponte
beaucoup d'hypothèses qui ont été donnés
sur la méthode de forme sur la méthode
de nidification élaboration mini aussi
savoir qu'ils pondent est quoi le sud de
la france c'est parti enfin même s'ils
sont plusieurs bassins sédimentaires du
camp toute cette zone est sans doute une
des plus grosses si ce n'est la plus
grosse le plus gros gisement fossilifère
de youzhny concurrencer les clés des
sud-américains pour ce qui est des
dégâts l'eau liquide et donc c'est cette
famille duff con
on trouve en surnombre en provence cas
de marrant c'est que les sud-américains
entre c'est la même famille def
donc en fait ce serait une sorte de
spécificité de dire du pas de l'espèce
parce que c'est pas qu'une espèce mais
de la famille qui reprend du ce2 faire
des pontes en masse ce serait quelque
chose comme ça oui parfaitement
c'est assez compliqué toute cette
histoire sur les autres dinosaures
tout simplement parce qu'on ne trouve
pas d'un brouillon dans ses zones donc
la grande question pendant très
longtemps depuis des années 60 en tout
cas c'est de savoir qui pendait saison
donc ne sachant pas cela parce qu'on ne
pouvait pas d'embryons qui est lui tout
une toute une démarche de classification
des yeux qui ont été découverts une part
à taxonomie des oeufs qui aboutit donc à
la création d'une dizaine d'euros
espèces donc d'espèces 2 et parmi les
aux espèces et les zoos gens le plus
commun a le plus fréquent c'est mégalo
polypus donc de la famille des milieux
nous liquidez et c'est ceux là ont été
historiquement attachés aux iep celle
aux enfants quittent another d'avoir une
philosophie c'est ensuite au bo
titanosaures d'après l'abondance des
oeufs découvert en dessus de la france
et l'abondance de titanosaures
contribuer sachant que bon les
tyrannosaures étaient plus les plus
beaux qu'ils ont été été de très grosse
taille puisque les plus gros peuvent
atteindre plus de 25 cm de diamètre donc
historiquement attachés enfin rapporté
c'est cela ou titanosaures jusqu'à ce
que dans les années 2000 on est
découvert des embryons de titanosaures
dans des méga l'eau liquide et
sud-américains donc semaine de mégalo
l'écusson sont pas exactement les mêmes
les mêmes espèces provençal mais c'est
le même aux gens en tout cas et donc
depuis sa relance et la question savoir
bon on a bien affaire à des oeufs de
titanosaures sauf que donc là par contre
c'est une petite information qui est qui
a ces polémiques mais qu'il faudra en
tenir compte
en roumanie on a des gisements à mega
bloks idées qui ont été mis au jour
associé avec des jets des restes du
vinyle ou même de bébés poster closier
dan rose or donc là ça fait un peu un
peu la tâche dans tout ce qu'on
imaginait jusqu'à présent alors pour les
roumains une espèce de mégalo wikus donc
on appelle mégalo x series
sorede et huda droz a donc l'adresse
d'ortel matheuse russe qui adorent
vingtaine de cadavres humains
par contre pour les espagnols qui ont
découvert des agronomes et qui pour eux
à saucisse à d'autres d'autres eux les
mégalithes et mégalithes idée serait
purement des oeufs de titanosaures alors
après ce qui est étonnant ce qui est
intéressant c'est quand on compare la
biodiversité enfin la diversité des
oeufs de mégalo liquide et donc il sera
attribué des titanosaures et les fameux
smart de tout alors qu'on trouve dans le
sud de la france
on a beaucoup plus de différent que de
titanosaures différents donc soit on est
bien en dessous de la diversité des
dinosaures comme comme mes travaux le
laisse suggérer mais mais mais mais mais
résultats sont encore en dessous de la
diversité le désolant qu'on a découvert
soit en fait on pourrait avoir au sein
des mégalos liquide et peut-être une
mélange de plusieurs dinosaures du bord
qui pondent des oeufs se ressemblent en
tout simplement parce que ça dépend de
la papa ça me prendrait ça dépendrait
pas de facteur dans notre action de but
mais plutôt de facteurs environnementaux
et écologiques
c'est lui en question on a quelque chose
de très intéressant à à fouiller et puis
avec quelques milliers de rien qu'en
centre ville d'aix du coup cette
personne-là aura de quoi nous enseigner
pour le reste de sa vie
au lieu de cela alors juste une petite
précision si on n'a pas trouvé dans
brouillon en provence nous y pense c'est
tout simplement parce que les oeufs sont
éclos sens qu'il détail qui a son
importance sur le but de les deux qu'on
a trouvé on a très peu d'eux qu'ils ne
sont pas éclos et les hommes ont éclos
c'est aussi quelque chose de normal de
pas forcément fin de pas trouver
forcément un gagnant du temps puisque
quand on revient des poules
sacrée soirée poule pondeuse leclerc qui
sont partis donc pas d'un million à
l'intérieur six l'an passé la même chose
pour les études aux usa on a sur le
faible pourcentage des yeux qui atteint
des zones qui ne sont pas éclos on n'a
pas dans un trou et d'embryons dedans
alors soit c'était déjà clair soit les
conditions de sédimentologie qui n'ont
pas permis la préservation des embryons
qui n'était pas encore complètement
calcifié mai
est statistiquement non loin d'avoir
trouvé à 6,2 pour pouvoir trouver des
embryons compte parmi toute cette
quantité de matériel alors on les trouve
chez eux on les trouve sur une grande
surface dans le sud de la france mais on
les trouve aussi sur une épaisseur de
sédiments assez impressionnante
on a une hypothèse pour expliquer cela
en fait on se rend compte que les sondés
qui sont souvent découverts dans des
sédiments qui résulte dans ces plaines
d'inondation qu'en général quand même eu
et un guide
elle peut marécageuse autour des
rivières ben ça permet de masquer
l'odeur ou dehors des oeufs l'odeur des
et des herbivores et les prédateurs bon
perdre la trace de leurs proies dans ces
niveaux là c'est pour ça qu'on trouve
actuellement beaucoup de beaucoup
d'heureux jours qui viennent un petit
bien le terme leur nid en bord de
rivière en bord de fleuve dans des zones
marécageuses souvent qui sont en plus
très riche en plantes comme les roseaux
des plantes à ces votes donc qu'ils vont
masque aussi la vie la visibilité donc
le comportement des autres actuelle
reflète sûrement le comportement donc on
parle beaucoup on parle beaucoup de des
continents du sud elle va particulier
l'amérique du sud puisque apparemment il
ya des fortes similitudes entre les
dinosaures bien de chez nous et ceux de
l'amérique du sud les titanosaures par
exemple avec le très célèbre
argentinosaurus me semble c'est un
titanosaures donc dans une famille que
notre en peloso russe nationale et de
l'autre côté on a on a le raptor et
alors ça les raptors fait penser à
l'amérique du nord ça me fait penser à
la mongolie alors c'est quoi c'était un
peu le carrefour de la biodiversité des
dinosaures chez nous c'est ça bah c'est
simple que ça en fait c'est une image
assez proche de ce qui devait être la
configuration des phoques
donc il faut savoir quelle époque déjà
en europe c'est un archipel d'îles comme
je disais tout à l'heure
libero américaine était décidée une de
ces îles
c'était la plus grosse désillusion pn on
a d'autres missiles qui était qui
composaient cet archipel là l'autre plus
qu une autre qui est très connu ces
deals
delsey guil roumaine sur lesquels on a
découvert toute la faune roumaine
transylvanienne pour reprendre le terme
l'historique et ensuite on a par exemple
en vous rend en gris dans des niveaux un
peu plus ancien parc indécente orléans
donc si les niveaux qui étaient là et
qui a cueilli une forme de dinosaure
assez riche
donc on a d'autres il qu'ils sont
répartis sur des agissements qui sont
pas forcément bien fumier ou qui n'ont
pas donné de choses intéressantes
ce qu'il faut retenir donc c'est que
l'archipel européen comprenez cros
grosso modo la surface de l'europe
géographique actuelle sauf ça que c'est
il s'agissait d' île et l'europe à
l'époque était bien plus bas dans vers
le sud puisque c'est elle occuper la
position du maroc actuel et cet archipel
était en fête au milieu en quasiment au
milieu de la thétys qui est donc cet
ancien aussi ancien maire dans le maire
qui qui séparaient donc les continents
du noir la mort asie et les continents
du sud le congo n'a pas ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on l'a trouvé dans
des dinosaures qui proviennent du sud
comme les habits nourrit des dettes mais
titanosaures qui ory donc émigrés la
femme immigrée sur les îles européenne
suit avec des passages temporaires comme
les des mères profondes ou parlera par
l'intermédiaire de radeaux et de dalles
côté on a des phones qui sont plutôt qui
présente des affinités avec les
continents du nord comme les fameux
drones et autres événements sacha qu'on
prouve aussi des rapports en amérique du
sud ham s'est pas tout à fait les mêmes
mais les deux hommes et deux roues
motorisés sont plutôt noirs américains
et asiatiques
on a aussi ramené donc rabobank qui par
contre lui une l'a spécifié spécificité
de cet archipel la halle et si on
remonte dans le temps des dinosaures les
plus proches qui auraient pu être les
plus proches de l'unss être durable dans
saw v noirs américains comme le tenant
aux russes qui étaient donc à dinosaures
nord-américain du jurassique donc sans
doute que l'erap de dons proviennent les
premiers devraient 2
le même bilan mais sachant qu'à cette
époque là enfin l'époque de l'ancêtre du
rab ou dont l'amérique du nord enfin le
mans donnerait le gondwana il avait
alors asie était beaucoup plus proches
mère encore connectés donc là on peut
cet ancêtre brume se trouvent en afrique
ont pu se balader un peu partout sans
vraiment être gêné donc voilà donc en
par contre pour le crétacé supérieur on
a clairement des villes qui sont séparés
de tous ces continents la collectionnite
et au delà des animaux des familles qui
colonisent les îles les unes après les
autres et des fois n'atteignent pas
certaines villes par exemple on a des
cératopsidés qui proviendraient de
l'asic qui ont réussi à atteindre la
roumanie mais qui n'ont pas pu venir
jusque 10 sur 10 que sur lili novembre
kane est par exemple les habits les
rides et les plus gros pas les plus
petits mais les plus gros n'ont pas pu
aller en roumanie pour moi on n'a pas
trouvé de reste de gros add the rib et
oromin dit qu on a mérou mais les
roumains ont découvert un petit fémur
dhabi torride et sans doute un adulte
qui serait plus apparenté à tarascon il
s'agit nous aurons donc à cette autre
vague d'abily droid est donc peut-être
un peu plus ancienne que celle des gros
d'égo comme un robin à tort qu'ils ont
vécu en provenance de l'europe était un
espèce de filtre un filtre écologique en
entre les comptes entre les continents
du nord et du sud qui ont été colonisés
de manière fin de plusieurs directions
possibles et de manière plus ou moins
total par des pointillés en gros qui
reliait les continents et qui à qui il
est qui filtrait aussi le passage ça
peut-être ce que j'aurais ce que
j'aurais dû préciser avoir ma question
c'est aussi parce que on va avoir des
grands et des petits qui vont
certainement écouter cette émission il
faut bien préciser c'est que il ya tous
les dinosaures n'ont pas vécu au même
endroit dont tu parlais justement là
cela m'a interpellé du décès râteau
tient donc la famille du triceratops
tricératops y en avait pas partout mon
coin du voile par exemple les cerrato de
6,1 sont des animaux qui sont
typiquement d'une horde hémisphère nord
qu'on va trouver en amérique du nord et
en asie dont 12 ont l'occasion lors
asiatiques et du coup alors en france tu
dis pas de sérieux maintien
certes on vous puisque à preuve du
contraire peut-être jusqu'à preuve du
contraire
bon je pense que dans la quantité de
fossiles qu'on a trouvé les strates
options on aurait pu on lui trouve
quelque chose depuis le temps mais bon
c'est peut-être le même problème que
pour les ans qu'ils osent avant
d'encaisser un taux de chiens
contrairement au 100 kg d'or il laisse
quand même pas mal de temps derrière eux
c'est plus facile à retrouver j'imagine
on a des dents on a beaucoup de gens
dedans kg dans les collections du muséum
d'histoire naturelle d'aix en provence
contiennent environ une vingtaine de
dames qui nous manque c'est la plus
grosse collection de 90 kg zordi
d'europe
donc on les trouve quasiment sûr en
train d'être est un philosophe quasiment
sur tous les tous les jugements corso
donc pensé qu'ils étaient là c'est
qu'ils étaient en province mais
peut-être pas sur le gisement à
proprement parler c'est pour ça qu'on
trouve pas plus de l'ossement on connaît
pas bien leur écologie elle reste qu'ils
étaient plutôt tranchés par l'arrière
pays bas où il y avait des forêts ou là
où la végétation était plus rares bons
on sait pas trop mais en tout cas les
danakil aux angles
donc c'est pas un animal rare c'est
celle à la découverte d'ossements plus
complet keira ça qui est paradoxal et
ses fruits 3 et ses trousses
on sait qu'il est là et on n'arrive pas
à l'identifier d'accord alors maintenant
ben justement puisqu'on est en pleine
remise en contexte national et
international
on va dire la grande star des gisements
à dinosaures de france en ce moment du
moins ce qui a le vent en poupe c'est en
jacques avec avec des campagnes de
fruits qui font l'objet d'une couverture
médiatique assez conséquente ans les a
vus il ya pas longtemps à égaler de
schiste par exemple donc par rapport à
par rapport à jacques comment se situe
on va dire dans l'espace dans le temps
et au niveau diversité de dinosaures
comme on recommencera situé à
aix-en-provence par rapport à jacques
alors là il faut imaginer enfin il faut
bien qu'on a affaire à deux mondes
totalement différents
déjà que c'est un gisement qui l'a du
crétacé moyens donc que l'on est donc
prête à ses supérieurs voire terminale
donc on a oui beaucoup plus anciens donc
des 30-34 d'années d'écart entre du
gisement donc c'est quand même assez
conséquent et on a aussi des fans qui
sont totalement dit
40 les assemblages de pointe qu'ils sont
c'est totalement différent de celui de
provence
on a des dinosaures qui n'existe plus en
provence les comptes courants ou jack en
minimes aux orques immigrants jacques
mais qui n'existent n'ont pas été
découverts en provence simplement ce qui
n'existait pas la lisibilité ailleurs
mais pas en provence je pense par
exemple aux ordis tommy minet qui sont
ces fameux liés aux autruches donc on a
des représentants primitive quand même
découvert à angeac ces dinosaures là
n'ont pas été découverts dans le crétacé
supérieur de provins de provence ni même
de delisle ibéro américaine on a par
exemple au niveau des sauropodes donc ce
gigantesque sauropodes de charente
apparemment ce serait pas forcément un
petit another d'après d'après les dents
qui ont été trouvés plutôt une forme de
de titanosaures reform basale cesser
complètement différent de ce qu'on a dit
ce qu'on est en provence au niveau des
carnivores aussi parce que là on a
plutôt affaire à des l'allosaure huahine
la grande famille qui contient qui
contient à l'onu sous d'autres souffre
ali comme comme baryonyx est nouveau
tout ça donc se dit pas qu'on m'a dit
spinoza ans jacques on a peut-être dès
que des cousins des cousins qui nous en
a sur ce gisement là puisqu'on à la
trouver sur des gisements contemporain
ans jacques royaume uni ou en espagne
donc voilà donc c'est cette femme très
différentes elles ces parties de l'île à
libéraux armoricaine géographiquement
parlant
à cette époque la ville n'a pas du tout
la même superficie les la connexion que
celle du crétacé supérieur que donc
voilà donc c'est vraiment deux mondes
deux mondes radicalement différent au
niveau des compères et des comparaisons
c'est enfin on a beaucoup de difficultés
un pur moment parce qu'on n'a pas les
résultats déjà debout pas et en plus
parce que les familles sont pas les
mêmes et si ce sont les mêmes on a des
écarts et boultif assez important entre
les espèces accorde encore jacques est
plus ancienne mais les espèces qui
peuplent ce gisement ne sont pas les
ancêtres de sel d'aix-en-provence pour
le moment peut pas le dire en tout cas
de ce qui est connu un bon jack on n'a
pas de descendants en provence ça c'est
certain pour le moment ça va bien
insister là dessus c'est pas du tout les
mêmes espèces alors ça ça souligne un
autre point important et souvent on va
dire assez méconnu c'est que les
dinosaures donc des gens on les dit tout
d'ailleurs s'est pas les mêmes dans
l'espace c'est pas les mêmes dans le
temps
à angeac les dinosaures ils ont tué à
dire sont 20 à 30 millions d'années plus
vieux que ceux d'aix-en-provence
on va mettre un repère pour nous ça nous
amène à peu près à la moitié de la
distance qui nous sépare du dernier des
dinosaures
c'est quand même une quantité de temps
qui est impressionnante anouilh ya 30
millions d'années
nos ancêtres vivaient dans les arbres et
manger des feuilles donc là c'est ouais
c'est un point important je pense qu'il
faut souligner pour pour nos auditeurs
c'est tous les dinosaures sont pas les
mêmes et ça ça rend les comparaisons
encore plus compliqué puisqu'il faut
tenir compte de cette différence dans
l'espace de ces différences dans le
temps les innocents dont qassimi de nous
de nous surprendre quand on voit qu'on a
découvert des dinosaures bas le fameux
spinosaurus qui maintenant sur un
dinosaure qui se fait plutôt plutôt
fluviatile world une mother qui
pétrissent heures avec le royaume uni
n'a pas fini d'être surpris par rapport
à l'étendue des adaptations de ces
dinosaures identifiantes niche
écologique possible sans compter les
zozos alors j'ai envie de dire pour
terminer une interview sur les
dinosaures l'inévitable thème c'est
l'extinction
oui extinction qui est pas tellement une
extinction qui est une page assez noir
de l'évolution des dinosaures qui ne
s'est pas arrêté pour autant alors tout
simplement puisque le thème de la vidéo
ces dinosaures de france est-ce que les
dinosaures de france à ce que ce qu'on
trouve des dinosaures en france donne
des indices sur les îles différentes
hypothèses concernant l'extinction de
ces tunisiens avant pâques à un moment
on en fait on a un petit problème dans
le sud de la france et que le dernier
niveau géologique qui enregistre donc
cette fameuse limite crétacé tertiaire
la fameuse 2004 n'ont pas été
enregistrées en fait ils ont été
enregistrés mais les sédiments
n'existent plus ils ont été érodées une
bonne partie de la france donc on n'a
toujours pas trouvé 7
limites physiques et fameux dépôt
d'argile noir qui sont très riches en
lithium est très pauvre en fossiles
cette limite là qu'on traite on n'a pas
encore dans le sud de la france
les espagnols du côté pyrénéen sont en
train de chercher ils ont opéré de
manière assez précise de l'endroit où se
situer la limite mais ils n'ont pas
encore la limite apprendre à parler mais
en tout cas pour le sud de la france
on n'a pas donc les dinosaures du sud de
la france ne permettent pas réellement
de répondre à la question à d'alimenter
de tout là toute la nuit et toute la
conversation qu'il ya sur l'extinction
des dinosaures non aviens pour éviter d
oslo mais qu'est ce qu'on peut dire tout
simplement c'est qu'en provence
paradoxalement les dinosaures provençaux
qui pour les plus récents dans date de
62,6 millions d'années alors que
l'extinction des dinosaures en la
fameuse crise à dieu il ya 65 millions
d'années
mais il ya 65 millions d'années déjà les
dinosaures ont 10 enfin on n'en trouve
plus donc pendant 2 3 millions d'années
on a pu le dinosaure en provence
pourquoi ça on en a encore aucune idée
contre +2 entre puis dos entre quelques
mollusques mais on a eu le versement
écologique en tout cas en province qui
n'a pas permis la conservation de
dinosaure dans des gisements dans des
environnements de dépôt qui sont les
mêmes que ceux qu'on trouve quelques
millions d'années en avant alors par
contre dans le cas est assez terminal du
sud ouest de la france ont trouvé une
osera se sont pas encore tout à fait les
derniers puisqu'on en parle et bernise a
envie son nom biologie comme je disais
mais là on a une foi de newser beaucoup
plus récente qui ressemble beaucoup à
celle qu'on trouve une bande noire de
l'espagne et qui montre déjà qu'à la fin
à la fin du crétacé ou que durant
les derniers 10 millions d'années on a
un bouleversement écologique assez
important où que ce soit au niveau de la
faune de la flore mais aussi du climat
et pendant les tout derniers millions
d'années on a on a aussi une grosse un
gros bouleversement qui va conduire à
l'asservissement de des dinosaures et
ensuite leur disparition
alors quand je dis faiblissement des
innocents c'est qu'on s'est rendu compte
que sur les tous derniers millions
d'années pour être précis les lébous 3
millions d'ha 2 millions d'années juste
avant la crise qu'a t on se rend compte
que en amérique du nord par exemple
là on a des très bons enregistrements
fossiles on a une diversité des
dinosaures qui qui commençait à abc
alors que jusqu'à présent
jusqu alors qu'avant on avait plutôt une
diversité qui détient était le double
donc donc on l'a ces dinosaures qui
commencent à se raréfier mais avoir des
familles de moins en moins nombreuses
on a beaucoup de candidats encore mais
au niveau des herbivores on a des grands
famille comme il faisait un but de
canard et jade rose or on a plus je
pense plus qu'on est de 2,2 soit opposé
à cette époque là et malheureusement
c'est durant cette période où la
diversité des familles dinosaures
vincent - de guerre qu'on va avoir des
événements écologique très important
comme les perturbations liées à l'
impact météoritique on imagine qu en
afrique du nord où le veau gagny le
volcanisme en inde qui vont venir
finalement comme un couple aurait
assassiné les familles enfin cette
diversité qui était en train de en train
de se en train de s'affaiblir alors
pourquoi cette diversité s'affaiblissent
et avant même l'extinction des
dinosaures
on pense que c'est lié à des gros
changements climatiques globaux qui
eux-mêmes sûr lié à la tectonique des
plaques
vu que les continents sous l'été la
technique était en train de bouger les
uns par rapport aux autres et qu
occupait déjà la fin du crétacé une
position assez proches de ceux
d'aujourd'hui il à part quelques
quelques exceptions comme comme l'inde
donc les continents avaient une position
assez similaire de 7 aujourd'hui donc
les courants océaniques qui sont mis en
place ont changé entre l'entrée et à ses
moyens et le crétacé terminale on a déjà
commencé a dit conte
tellement été bouleversés et on sait que
les courants ciani qui sont le moteur du
climat
donc à la fin du crétacé en température
baisse s'est notablement puisqu'on a
même à la toute fin du mas riu chiendent
présence de des luttes quelques colères
qui se forme en antarctique
alors que ce n'était pas du tout le cas
d'aurore est assez il ya ceux là donc
c'est ajouter donc l'impact météoritique
au mexique et les trapps du deccan donc
en inde qui même si l'on peut si ces
deux événements n'ont pas été
strictement contemporains ont très
largement déséquilibré l'écologie
mondiale dans leur région respective et
qui ont malheureusement joueurs défaveur
des dinosaures qui était déjà bien
affaiblie par les changements de
température qui eux mêmes en changer la
la végétation qui qui pouvait les
continents d'accord et donc en france on
a en gros des dinosaures vers la fin du
crétacé on a des dinosaures qui
s'absentent en quelque sorte
alors est ce que c'est les mêmes qui
reviennent après ou est-ce que c'est
d'autre trois espèces alors au crétacé
terminal dinosaures qui s'absentent ne
revienne plus jamais par exemple le
tyrannosaure et les radios dont vous
d'après les théories les plus récentes
sont remplacés par les arrosant qui
envahissent leur a alors cet
envahissement des adresses hors service
selon selon lui ce dimanche au log le
paléobotanique hui à l'apparition et à
l'expansion des enjeux ce père donc les
plantes à fleurs les plantes à fleurs
vont se répandre partout dans le monde
qui s'est donc le une des
caractéristiques d'un changement
climatique assez important et l'île aux
orres qui n'était pas adapté à cette
cette flore là vont disparaître c'est le
cas de titanosaures et des radios dans
ce long de 40 selon les hypothèses est
reconnaissante
par contre les rats de dont les iléades
rose or et viscérale obtient qui ont des
questions des dents
particulière eux étaient
vraisemblablement adapté à ce genre de
flore et en truand très facilement
perdurer jusqu'à la fin du crétacé en
tout cas en europe mais dans un monde d
à 3 heures partout dans le monde
peut-être dans l'hémisphère nord même
parmi les reçus mais surtout on a mis ça
dans l'hémisphère nord donc le site de
dornach ont des culs jusqu'à la fin du
crétacé par contre de provence ceux qui
ont disparu ne robin plus l'écart avec
le monde des dinosaures c'est pas le
monde des bisounours qui serait signé
c'est la vie un dinosaure et est adapté
un milieu et à une nourriture donnée si
cette nourriture ou si le lieu a changé
elle va changer d'avis la zorn a soit il
s'adapte soit on disparaît l'adaptation
est en plus lente que la disparition
il est très courante voire des animaux
disparaître au profit de l'espèce qui
sont qui sont mieux armés pour survivre
dans cet environnement qui change
ils sont même pas filer un coup de main
entre arrêtés et sont patents entre les
deux ans impitoyable je crois qu'on a
bien fait le tour de la question en tout
cas s'il fallait faire découvrir aix en
provence l'extraordinaire patrimoine
qu'on y découvre ccpcp refait donc je
remercie beaucoup
thierry d'or - votre service pour vous
présente le dire au revoir à tout le
monde et à très bientôt